no I'm Chloe I'm Danny and we've been
together just over here I think like a
year in three months Wow so exact the
way that we've had offers like
one-on-one like meet up I really want to
hear more details about what you thought
about that situation yeah we kind of
knew each other before we started dating
like we barely turn around
yeah few times three times why are you
three times before we don't use Wow he
has no memory as man a year in three
months but that was made up yeah I'm
more interested in like what your
thoughts were of me at the time because
obviously that's something that I don't
really know I first met Danny and August
of 2017 at a pool party that our friend
was throwing it's her birthday that's
the first time I met her I thought she
was not bad to look at she was there
with an ex-boyfriend and I remember
seeing Danny and he was like super
friendly and sweet and funny for the
first time ever since meeting my ex I
was like wow this guy's cute because I'm
really good at being very very very
faithful in relationships and I was like
oh I'm finding another guy attractive
this isn't a good thing I think we hung
out one more time was that another
mutual friend's birthday thing I
remember and then I met him a couple
more times after I broke up with my ex
just like through mutual friends cuz we
both went to the same acting school he
invited me and like all my other friends
to this like Christmas ugly sweater
party that he throws every year I didn't
think she would come
I was pretty newly single so I was like
oh I want to go I want to see what boys
are there but also school Danny's there
because he's cute so I went and he was
pretty drunk so I was dancing a lot and
there she was her and her sister showed
up he was all over the place but it was
funny I tend to sweat a lot so why not a
good first impression or a third I was
like oh he's never gonna know yeah like
eva's it's never gonna happen he's
really flirtatious just as a person so I
just thought he doesn't like me he just
likes that's how he is with people well
I didn't actually think that she liked
me actually I specifically remember
thinking she wasn't interested so I kind
of just left it at that and went on my
way of drinking and forgetting I didn't
know if I really wanted to ask him out
because I didn't know if that was like
too fast after my other boyfriend I
ended up at the end of the night being
like because he has a big youtube
channel
genuinely wanted to find out about like
how to build my personal channel so I
was like hey would you want to meet up
and gave me some advice on YouTube and I
genuinely meant that and I wasn't asking
him out I think he for he thought I was
I bet she definitely said that she might
have been interested but she really
wanted to learn about the YouTube stuff
he was like yeah Facebook messaged me
didn't give me his number
a few days later I got a Facebook
message from her I came here exactly how
it was put was like you know okay would
you like to hang out sometime and talk
about YouTube I thought it was a little
odd
she works at BuzzFeed so I thought you
know she probably can navigate YouTube
pretty well by herself we met up on a
Friday night which I thought was quite
interesting cuz he picked Friday and I
was like this is a business meeting
Friday night is a lot so I kept asking
all my friends I was like is this a date
you think she's into me
I didn't know so I was a little anxious
and he went to meet in a bar and I was
like this is a business meeting calm
down 20 I that I can kind of see the
night I remember if we were at a booth
she would be on this side I was on this
side I think I had a whiskey sour cuz I
was nervous and I'm sure she was nervous
too so you know you gotta get drinks in
you we ended up just like talking about
YouTube and stuff then it went on so
like everything I think we got there
8:00 and didn't leave till 1:00 a.m. I
was like filling her out to try to
figure out if she actually liked me or
if she was just interested in the
YouTube stuff he started to be like
touchy but then again he touches
everyone we kind of you know a lot of
flirting touching type of thing and I
was like well this is taking a long time
for business meeting but I would have
left by now so I started to think I
think maybe he likes me obviously she
wasn't with her ex-boyfriend anymore I
wasn't seeing anybody so these are all
you know pointing in the right direction
and now the sex happened and it was like
closing so we had to leave and we both
got lifts and we're waiting outside the
bar and I hugged her and she hugged back
I think I was about to say goodbye to
him and then I kind of leaned forward we
kind of looked at each other and I was
like maybe a kiss would be cool and he
kissed me so we made out a little bit I
think at this time the lyft driver was
there so he got the watch just make out
which is always fun I like an audience
it was kind of with kiss
just cuz it felt very like on the way
home she texted me saying I honestly
this wasn't what I wanted I wasn't
trying to hook up I was honestly wanted
to talk about you to likely story and
then I had to like wait to see if he was
gonna text to me and I was like oh my
god is he gonna text me did I mess up
like should that have happened did he
really kiss me what did I kiss him what
happened and he ended up tasting me and
he wanted to hang out cuz I was going
home for Christmas in like a few days we
went on another date
more more makeout yeah that was that
then we texted over the break cuz she's
in England I was in Oklahoma and yeah
okay thing that I can actually date this
girl I have never really had detailed
version of his side of it so I want to
know what he thought and what he thought
was a harlot that was like chasing after
him whether he just you know thought it
was business I've said business three
times
she probably tails pride less rambling
probably didn't mention all the making
out figure this is just for my own
benefit
alright let's cut it were you really
interested in the YouTube thing are you
just trying to get with this well that
was my like easy way in to like get to
know you better but it wasn't like that
was a complete lie I was asking
everybody that's like oh god what do I
do
panic got it check now you seem quite
confident on the date today it wasn't a
date whoops see it lik immediately I
think it's a date God baiting is so
confusing it is what would you have done
if I'd just straight out been like hey
wanna go on date next week right even
yes oh maybe I should be more forward
next time next turn s to you
[Music]